basic machine
uh programming for face and turn part is
really quite simple on nasa so generally
you'll start with
left soft key and you'll hit your
program button here
now you'll want to edit a work number
you pull it up a work number
and if you don't already have a work
number it's okay because if you just put
in
whatever work number that is oops
that's fine generally you can't have
more than
four digits in a row without a dash
uh on the lathe the mills are different
but do that hit enter it will ask you
to either have a new program menu you'll
have
a mazda troll program or you can do a
general g-code program
which isn't terribly difficult if you
know g
code it's really quite simple magic
troll is obviously something that not
everyone knows
really matter troll and the first thing
i'll ask you is what your material is
this does not matter
if you care about your feeds and speeds
because
all this is is just conducting fees and
speeds that are
in its computer to automatically input
if you don't know what you want to do
so we'll just do carbon steel because i
don't care
they'll ask you next what is the max
outer diameter of your workpiece od
max so 2.5 inches is what i'm going to
input here
id you don't have to have anything here
if you're not doing an id
so an id minimum you don't even have to
put anything there
length i want a five inch length
work face now this is however much
you're facing off of the part
and generally that facing off the part
will be your z zero so you'll put in
i want to take off 50 fell off of this
side of the part
so i'll put in zero five point zero five
rpms this will max out this will tell
you
it tells you exactly how much rpm that
the machine is going to have
just in the program itself this is for
the whole program
this is not for anything else if you
want to max out your rpm or
limit in different parts of the program
you have to use m codes
this does not apply to live tooling live
tooling is in tool data
the live tooling yes exactly the live
tooling max
rpm is in its cool data this one i'll do
1500 even though it's kind of slow
so when you're facing it will only go
down to 1500
so it's surface foot per minute well max
will actually start getting smaller
as it goes down that 1500 is going to
max out
so our first our first unit
is going to be turning because we want
to face the parts we're going to hit
turning
there are two different ways you can
face a part in here actually there's
several ways but
i'm going to do the simplest one for
this example i'll do a bar
face
cutting point x tells the machine
exactly where it wants to start
the cutting point if you go two inches
it's going to start cutting at two
inches
but our max od for our part is 2.5 we
cannot go higher than 2.5 or else it
will alarm out it needs to know where to
start
we're gonna go 2.5 inches our cutting
point z
will be zero because that is where i'm
going to have it set up
our finish allowance and x is going to
be point zero
three doesn't have to be and
it really doesn't matter on a facing
pass what does matter on a facing pass
is you're finished in z because it's
going this way
put in 0.003 you know that also doesn't
necessarily matter
now if you want to do two passes you
want a rough pass and a finish pass
even though you have 50 pounds
you have a rough pass and a finish pass
you can
have it come in rough it out and leaves
three thou
and z you finish it with but i don't
want to do that
i want to make one single pass
for this particular use so i will go
over here
right softy and with my cursor
on the first side general i'll hit erase
and it will highlight
the first part so it'll have rub
and finish
so i'm just going to have a finish pass
if you have a rough tool that will run
the rough part of the program
the finish tool will only run the finish
part of the program
[Applause]
now here we will
most people don't like using these but
you can if you want
um it is useful especially if you're
doing multiple facing passes
this will leave a finish a finished
stock
finish allowance x this is basically
leaving stock in x and z
for the tool that will come in in front
of it for
after it to take off more material if
you so wish
however i don't want it to do that i
want to be one pass and i want to be
done with it
so i'm going to cut my cutting surface
speed which is
probably already going to max it out at
two and a half inches so i'll just set
800 or 800 surface foot
feed rate your feed rate will be
0.08
here you'll have m codes if you want to
put an m8 in here for your coolant you
can have that here
you can have an m0 for a program spot
we could have an m1 for optional stop
you can have a different m code for
whatever else you desire
so now yeah we add coolant to it because
we want to keep it cool as it does this
big fast which is
it's not a big pass no so now that we're
done with this particular line
we have now described the basic shape of
the part it's cutting points where it's
going to start cutting
and x and z
and then we're going to describe what
tool it is
it is a finish tool so it's going to run
the finished part of the program
that is a tool description of general
edge the tool number is number 10 on the
turf
now that we're finished with all of that
we can arrow down one and it will ask us
pattern of figure pattern of figure
designates do i want to cut a line do i
want to cut a taper
do i want to cut a convex shape
a concave shape
or i don't know what that one is i did
learn it at one point but i never use it
so i don't remember
in this particular case i will want to
use line
because i want to cut a straight line
down in x
to x zero start corner
when you do a start corner on
a mazek it will almost always give you a
45 degree chamfer
that 45 degrees because generally if
you're going to make a corner break on
anything any print in the world almost
always has a 45 degree chamfer it's
extremely simple
it's something that you're going to run
into all the time so
it will always be a 45 degree start
corner if you put one in
now if you want to make a radius a round
radius you'll hit
corner r right there
and if i want to make that radius say
150 fellow radius
from the top of the part to the front of
the part
i can point in 0.15
so that'll be a central tool path but if
i want to make it a corner
i just arrow back over here i'll put in
point zero three that is a thirty thou
forty five degree corner break
it will always be forty five degrees
unless
your tooling is not described properly
and that 30 cell is measured in linear
z linear x it is not 30 cell across
the length of the angle yeah
so now that we also notice there's a
diamond
in x and z for its start points because
it already gets our start points from
our cutting points
x and z all right it'll only ask us for
our final point
x our final point x is going to be x0 to
face off the part all the way if you
don't want to go there
if you want to face if you're facing off
tube stock
you can face at the half inch so you can
face down to a half inch
or if you're running a big drill in
there you can face down to whatever this
like 100 thou below the drill diameter
so in this case i want to do
zero finish point z zero
again that's an extremely simple way to
start programming
if i want to do a final corner which you
can't necessarily do
on a face it doesn't make doesn't make
sense why would i do a corner
here or here in a face i had to think
about that like i would write it i would
write a separate program
to come in with a tool that's based in z
to come and cut a corner or a radius in
the face of the part
then you can do under cutting tool yeah
an undercutting tool or any variety or
anything else
so you don't have to do anything now
finish surface finish speed rate menu
this is another auto setting based off
of
what your what your material is in his
computer this is
preset things and whatever you told it
that
your tool is another finish
sort of deal so it'll go you can either
do roughness
so one is roughest nine is nicest and
smoothest
this is nice for mills because it does
actually work on mills
it doesn't always work on lathes it's
kind of weird
but i don't want to do that now it says
feed rate five nine here
you want to override that feed rate for
any particular reason you can always hit
feed rate per revolution
and i just want to make it eight vowel
rev
very conservative speeds eight power rep
will override will override what the
feed rate
is set here this will always override it
um
so from this point i'll hit shake end
down here
this will end this this entire this is
one block
this will come in come down to 2.5
cut the chamfer and face down to x0
and it's easier position so now i want
to turn
a half inch off of this part but i can't
turn a half inch all in one shot
they might shoot the part out of the
lathe well maybe this lathe but
maybe not another way
so i will hit turning
again just like we did before bar
out cutting point x this is before 2.5
it has to know
where our material is or else it's going
to cut air or it's going to slam into it
you have to give it what it is it
doesn't pull the alarm out
this is me up for you you're
telling it
where the material is you're not telling
it's the exact starting point you're
telling it where to expect the toilet so
if your material is bigger than this
it will wrap it say if you're five
thousand bigger than this it'll rapid
five thousand
maybe a little bit closer but a little
less close because there are buffers and
you set your buffers
and your cpc information in this program
however
cutting point z will be zero because z
is
zero is our face zero
finish allowance i want to put thirty
foul finish so i can have a nice finish
on this part
finish allowance in z i don't want any
actually i do want a little bit because
when we make that shoulder
of our turn we're going to be leaving a
step from our rougher
and we want to take that out 0.05
so now it will give you drop finish
general out and then it will give you
your tool numbers
if you have tools that are suitable for
this sort of thing
it will already tell you it'll
automatically set them from your food
data
pattern zero and one
are generally almost what you're going
to use all the time
will come up to that shoulder and then
it will turn up
one will come up to the shoulder and
then wrap it back wrap it back to the
front of the heart and keep turning
the difference is the shape imploded
tool comes in goes straight up makes a
straight 90 degree corner
if you have a dmv with a 55 degree
corner
it's going to leave that 55 degree
corner yeah it's going to leave a 55
degree
sort of relief up in here on your
shoulder and you're going to have more
material taking out
than your finish point and your z for
your finish allowance
which is kind of annoying and leads to
quite a bit of chatter if you don't know
that's what's going on or just break the
whole turtle straight and break
the tools too
um the machine doesn't care if you
remember that zero is what we're going
to use for this particular application
so i don't have a print here but
basically we're going to have a
part that is going to be turned down to
two inches so we turn three inches back
and then it will have a shoulder that
goes up to its two and a half inch base
diameter
and then the top of that shoulder
there's going to be a 45 degree chamfer
there's going to be another 45 degree
chamfer here
compound angles we'll get into later
depth the max this will set the max
depth of cut
for your tool next step of cut
for our tool here will be 150 so 0.15
cutting speed you can always auto set
this but i don't like to
because sometimes this thing is wrong in
fact it's almost always wrong do it
yourself learn it yourself
so in this case i'll do 495 surface put
our feed rate per rev we're going to be
roughing it right
quite the speed so i'm going to be .015
so we'll take a 150 pound depth of
cutting this is depth of cut radially
this is not depth of cut
on the diameter the diameter will change
by 300
[Music]
not 150 this is a radial depth of cut
it'll almost always be a radial that's
gotten that counts for mills too
again we're going to find our m codes if
you don't know what your encodes are
you can always go and there are tons and
tons of m code menus in this machine
there for you to find you just follow
this arrow around
for this line we'll just use m8 for our
filament
now we have the same tool we're using
the same tool to finish with that we're
wrapping with because we
really don't care same sort of deal
we're not going to have any finish and
finish allowance and x for our finish
tool
because we want this to be two sides if
you make this 30 pound
it'll be 30 thou above what you tell it
to later
it is going to rough it 30 thou above
where you want it to be
and then it will do its finish pass at
what you say it's supposed to be
when we get down here if you hop it down
here two inches and you leave thirty
thousand
this will be two inch thirty thousand
the finish is gonna take it to two
inches
now if you say you want two inches so if
you leave the 15 in here
and x it'll be two inches uh
it'll cut only fifteen thousand at two
inches thirty thousand left from the
rougher
so it'll leave two inches fifteen
there's a lot of oversized plugs in the
main yeah
and the same thing for z it will leave
material from the finish pass so if you
want to make multiple finish passes this
is nice because you could just copy this
dimension
so you can copy your dimensions that
we're going to write out next to it and
you can make
a second or third or fourth finish you
would really desire to do that even
though i don't necessarily know why you
want
so i'm just going to hit input and keep
it at zero and now it'll still ask me
what my surface speed is
i'll give it a good 600
because i don't care what it looks like
i'll do the same thing i'll do a
.01 feed rate and an m8 so it has nice
good cooling on it
even though i don't care what it looks
like i don't want to burn my hand
pulling the damn thing out
so our first pattern
[Music]
will ask us you want to line the tape or
just like we did before up here
in this case i want to have a taper
because if this taper in the machine
this machine's been cutting for a while
and it's old
it'll have maybe one or two thousand
paper this way or that as it goes down
down the line in x and c well if it has
brand new ways
or it has brand new ways either way this
is you can use taper
taper line to accurately identify where
you want to go
we will be using tapers later when we do
compound angles
to teach more interesting things now i
want to give it a start corner
a start corner not a radius a corner
i want a nice 45 degree chamfer and it's
going to do that automatically
so i want to give it a .05
linear chamfer 45 degrees
now my start point and x
you don't have to care about what
material is on here because you're
actually
basically drawing what your print tells
you
it should be so my start point in x for
my diameter my final diameter is going
to be two inches
my finish point where my start point z
is going to be zero because that's the
face
right my finish point next is going to
be
say 2.001 so you have one thousand taper
and i don't want it in there
and it's tapering down now i can always
make it go
up one south and it will level it out
across these three inches
oops because i wrote three there
2.001
my final point in z is going to be
three inches final corner can be used
here but i prefer not to because it's
much less predictable so now i'll give
it rough the speed rate to rip
i still want to give it point zero one
so i'll give it point zero one that's my
feet right or wrap and that'll be my
override
now pattern of figure i just turned i
just made by diameter that's two inches
but i still want a chamfer
at the top of my two and a half inch so
i'm gonna do that now
and this is where we're going to be a
little bit more uh
interesting so taper again taper
now this is where it's going to start
changing we're not going to use a start
corner or a corner radius
a start point in x i'm going to use
interpolate that's what that stand in
purple is
i'll use a question mark for
interpolation
start point in z three inches
finish point in x 2.5 because i want to
have a chamfer at the top of my shoulder
2.5 2.5
finish point in z i want to have a 30
i want to have another 50 foul corner
so i'm going to go 3 inches plus 0.05
so 3.05
i'm going to skip the final corner
because this is
my final corner i'm writing it in so i
can more accurately control
final corner will always be whatever you
say it is
uh will always be a 45 or sometimes it
can be a radius
in here now
if you want a 30 degree chamfer up here
and not a 45
not a 45 you want to do 30 degrees
instead
you'll come over here it'll say taper
angle
30 degrees now all i do is i write soft
key
and i hit this button that says
calculate and this will go this will
interpolate
my start point in x to my finish point x
from my start point z to my finished
point in z
[Music]
come up to the nearest point in x and
that's how that works
so it'll always go from eight diameter
and a straight line to its next nearest
point next which is going to be 2.442
and then it will start cutting again
this will be feeding this will not be
blapping this will be feeding the whole
way now we're going to hit shape
because i don't care anymore i want to
end the program
because i am done with this damn thing
so continue i don't want to continue i
don't want to go to another program i
want
to just be this program number do i want
to give it a parts counter
sure that way i can keep track of how
many stupid things i'm making
return you can always turn it to its
tool change position
which is going to be a sync position it
automatically calculates it's called tpc
automatically calculates where is a safe
position according to its tool data
and where its z position is in the
machine
so tool change position there
work number next work piece number so if
you're making a flip
i'm not doing that so i'm not going to
fill it out and that's the end of my
so now i will give
you
shape check now do
shape continue
so again it'll face it it'll leave that
gigantic chamfer because you
one tick at a time so remember i said
it's always going to be a 45
right so i have a 45 degree chamfer
at 50 thou and then he wrote in a 300
[Music]
as well they are still both 45 the start
corner will always always always be at
but if i go back here just like i did
just now
i do say continue it'll show you this is
how it's going to write it's going to
face the part down to its x point the
center line
it'll come up it'll start roughing 150
foul at a time
and that'll leave that chamfer and then
it will
turn and it will come up and then break
that corner up there
everything you see in purple is the
finished
part except this everything is
now finished can actually watch it do
this if we want to we can go position
go back to our position page program and
now we can hit something called toolpath
this is the machine getting all the tool
data together
and figuring out what's there and what's
not
so if you don't have a tool here that
you don't if you have a tool like tool
number 10
which i don't want to use or tool 10
doesn't exist in my turret
then it will go hey what the heck's
going on i don't have this tool why are
you making me do this
so i don't want to use tool town i'm
going to have to edit this
i want to use tool number seven just
like i'm using for everything else so
i'm going to use
tool number seven but now you'll notice
there is a discrepancy of general edge
by a general out general edge and
general out are two different things in
tool data
here i'm just going to go general out
i'm going to switch that
so that's the same thing and it will be
aligned
in my tool data full data number seven
general out that's a right-handed
so i'm gonna go back to my program i'm
gonna hit toolpath
now that everything is there and there
should be no discrepancies i'll hit
heart shape right here and then i'll hit
f
continue for a past step path continue
will just run the whole thing and you'll
never see what's going on
so now let's start at two and a half
inches the green line
is always the rough stop the purple line
is the finished part
so we'll start at two and a half inches
we'll come over here
like it is and then it will start
turning that 300 pound
ungodly chamfer which it's never going
to do
without breaking an insert i mean it
might do it a few times but it's not
going to do it consistently
or safely i'm not optimistic so now i'll
get passed up again
and you'll notice it has it stops for a
second above the part
and then it brings it down above the
part again we'll do this again
[Music]
again there's this that goes
down to the part and then it begins to
cut that's just part of the tpc
it automatically in its parameters has
something that tells it
i have a buffer of x and z that way i
don't hit the thing
in case it's you know rough like really
rough stock and not a nice like turn and
pull it apart
but it's doing this if it's cutting that
way i can avoid that it doesn't fit the
hell out of your tool
now that it's cut my chamfer i can pass
up it again
and it will come down to x0
and you'll notice it is in front of that
home
icon it is in front of that yeah
because
so come up it'll bring the tool out away
from the part
we'll wrap it up i'll give you a part
shape that way you can see
i'll wrap it up and it'll do its first
turn this first turn here
is going to be 150 pound cut radially
this is not in diameter so whatever its
diameter at that point is is going to be
this minus 300 thousand
so 2.2 inches
just imagine that same line down here
yep
so that step it'll wrap it up
do this again it'll wrap it up
in a straight line straight line will
feed up in a straight line
it'll start to break that corner and
then it will go back
and then do its final rough turn when it
does that's
rough turn it leaves that 30 thousand
stock that we talked about earlier that
way we can finish our turn
it'll go up and x will
then miss everything it'll actually
interpolate
its first rough pass do a second rough
pass that way there's a nice straight
line
then it will wrap it back down i'll wrap
it down to its start x position which is
what we were looking at earlier for our
camper
it'll cut that tamper wrap it up or
turn all the way back at its speed rate
turn
up it'll turn up the rest of that that z
that we had that deposit that we had
there then it will finish our chamfer
and it will wrap it home and that will
be the end of our program
and it will also give you a rough path
very simple part very simple program but
it's a lot easier than writing decode
sometimes
[Music]
you